وفي موسكو قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
هناك حديثا يدور عن قيام القوات
الاوكرانيه بتنفيذ قتل متعمد ومنهجي بحق
الاسرى الروس وذلك باطلاق النار على رؤوس
اكثر من 10 جنود روس بعد تقيدهم
واضافت الوزاره ان القتل الوحشيه لاسرى
الحرب الروس يعتبر ممارسه شائعه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه هذا وكانت وسائل
الاعلام روسيه قد نشرت مقطعا قالت انه
مسرب ويظهر جنود اوكرانيين يطلق النار على
جنودروس مباشره بعد اثرهم
من جهته قال موقع ربار العسكري الروسي ان
الجانب الاوكرانيا نشر قبل ايام صورا جويه
لقتلى من القوات الروسيه قضوا في قصف
مدفعيه ببلده ماكيفتا بمقاطعه لوكا
واضافنا ذلك المقطع يتطابق مع صور عسكريين
ظهروا في الفيديو المسرب لعمليه الاعداء